so what's this doing here
hi so indeed want to encourage
discussion and there'll be no math in
this talk or very very little of it I
want to just talk about like the
implications and concepts of zero
knowledge poops and how they interact
with you know blockchains so just a
little bit about myself I've been
researching various forms of these
things I've called crypto proofs for
it's an informal term because there are
actually a whole variety of them and
they're very different since 2001
my personal uh ha moment so each one
everyone has their own aha moment about
blockchain so so mine was in in May 2013
and then I share a little bit with you
on what I over time learned about that
aha moment but I can summarize it it
like blockchains and crypto proofs work
very well together and I think now I can
better articulate why but at the time
was justice but I confessed it in
previous slides I called it Eureka but I
guess ok Eureka is more like I
discovered something really important to
humanity like he made this you know that
thing and it's this is more like you
know this is I realized something
personally as opposed to this led then
to being a founding scientist of Z cash
along with fair alessandro and five
others were the seven scientists of z
cash homage to the seven samurai of
akira kurosawa
and most recently i'm a co-founder and
chief scientist in the east of stark
where i layer covers the west he's also
co-founder and
chief scientist but in the West two
different companies one is doing one one
okz cash actually generated a coin
called Z cash I'm very happy you know
and n star cred does not have a coin and
there's other things I'll tell you a
little bit about our first product later
on but that's a little bit about myself
the talk over you I want to discuss
computational integrity as a general
value and different ways for different
ways to achieve it one of them is via
proofs then I want to talk about ZK is
at their best the correct of my biased
opinion others will find other
attributes and we'll call this family of
really nicely cake pieces ek Starks and
again it's a very biased view and then
again this will be very informal without
any like numbers or theorems or anything
and then I want to just describe this
very practical use case that will be on
blockchains
soon and like show you how you know
various attributes of this particular
zkp family can be used to solve problems
in blockchain so let's start with
computational integrity who's familiar
with this story raise your hand
oh it's a marvel okay this is a child
book rendition of this famous a Chinese
fable the tales of an emperor that
didn't have any children and he had to
select his heir so what he did is he
summoned all children in the kingdom and
gave each one of them a pot and a seed
and they were all instructed to take the
plant so this was in the autumn water it
every day and then come back on the
first day of spring and the Emperor will
select as his heir the one with the
prettiest flower so okay who knows the
rest of the story by now it's a really
good okay so the end of the story is
that everyone shows up with their pot
and you have these amazing flowers and
there's only one young child that stands
very much ashamed and has an empty pot
and then the emperor announces that the
one with the empty pot is the heir why
because all seeds that were given to
these children were barren and there was
only one child that acted with integrity
so it's a story about integrity
integrity is doing the right thing in a
reliable way and the value of integrity
that all of us you know appreciate and
aspire even though according to the
story it's a bit hard for humans to
actually achieve it this value of
integrity becomes much harder to
ascertain when you know the actions
you're doing or the instructions you're
told to take are not done in a public
domain they're done privately like you
know watering this flower in your home
and even more so when you have an
incentive to you know misreport the
output so that's integrity and
computational integrity is a similar
thing it is so we all the time hand over
instructions to computers these are
called computer programs and we want
them to sort of
operate according to those instructions
and report the output in a reliable way
and as time goes on more and more things
of importance are actually done on
computers you know all of the financial
world all of the healthcare forensics
everything goes through computers so so
much of our freedom and values and sorry
freedom in our property and you know
anything that is important to us more
and more of it is going onto computers
so there are often huge incentives it
could be reaching trillions of dollars
to misreport the outputs and and often
these computations are done in private
so we really really need to work in this
work to be in this world where you have
computational integrity where when a
computer is announcing its output you
know that this is indeed what it did
just like this in the story so this is a
value that we would like to have and
actually we do have it like you know our
banks are pretty much operating with
computational integrity when they're
computing whatever how much we have in
our balance and so on so and so forth so
I'm aware of four ways to achieve or you
know to enforce computational integrity
the first two are very prevalent and the
last two are sort of more new or less
prevalent in terms of how many systems
of great importance are covered by these
methods so the simplest one is naive
replay it basically means that whenever
some other party is doing a computation
that has great importance and I might
suspect that that it's not doing it you
know it might cheat I replay the same
computation so I asked for all of the
inputs and I basically recompute it and
if you think about it the reports that
we get from various financial
institutions or the tax forms that we
submit often are of this nature that
like any party receiving it can
basically recompute everything and just
check that they got the same result so
this is a very prevalent method and it
is widely adopted it doesn't really
prevent privacy doesn't scale very well
because every new entrant that wants to
that someone else did something okay
needs to basically recompute the same
computation it has this big advantage
that you really don't have to trust
anyone if you you want to know that
something is correct you just replay the
computation so in terms of trust it's
it's ideal and sorry this is a this is a
bug here it is also intractable to
compromise so like if I want to cheat
you that you know but you're gonna
naively replay any computation I did no
matter how much sorry okay this means
something good so it is intractable to
compromise right there's no amount of
money at my disposal that will make me
cheat someone else if he's doing a naive
replay of whatever I did now delegated
accountability is also this very
prevalent system that pretty much you
know between naive replay and delegated
accountability I think you covered for
like 99.99 percent of all stuff that
goes on in the world this is the process
of taking various people and delegating
to them the process of checking these
systems so you know regulators auditors
accountants right you you basically
appoint them to go to banks to health
care institutions or whatnot and sign
off on checking that computer and it
processes but a lot of them are computer
or computerized these days
signing off that everything is okay so
we we as a society delegate we appoint
these experts and we tell them go and
check that everything is ok on our
behalf so this is widely adopted it does
solve privacy concerns you know other
than the visa deleg delegated folks
others don't see what's going on it also
scales very well because you just send a
small group of people the downsides are
that you have to trust humans and
because of that if you're given enough
money or incentives you could actually
corrupt the system but you can go to
those folks and you know bribe them or
coerce them to sign off on things that
are not exactly correct and this does
happen
okay the newer the to newer kinds of
methods to achieve this so one is the
trusted execution environment so today
we have things like SGX previously it
was TPMS so this is like this sort of
hardened computer that you can't really
you know you send its some some
instructions into it but you know you
can't tamper with anything going inside
and will sign off internally on on the
correctness of the output so it's not
widely adopted it is very good in terms
of privacy because you know nothing goes
out of that execution environment at in
the best case it is mildly scalable
because the question is I mean these
these Hardware modules are rather small
and they cover small computations but so
so and you're limited somehow to that
size you have to trust in Hardware both
in these sort of physical assumptions
that you can't like look at this
hardware and extract these keys from it
and also in the hardware manufacturers
that put these keys that they won't
reveal them and because of that it's not
clear that it's intractable to
compromise I would actually make a more
strong statement that they are very much
tractable to compromise because from two
different angles first of all given
enough money you can bribe or coerce
someone that works at these
manufacturing plants to sort of tell you
what the keys that are being planted on
and another way that is completely
separate and this is what happened to
the TPMS back in the day is that some
physical processes were found that will
actually extract these signing keys from
from inside these models and once you
have this signing key you can basically
cheat very easily so they are somewhat
attractable to compromise and the last
one which is the focus of this talk is
is the notion of cryptographic proofs
often refer to as zk P's so again
they're like the trusted execution
environment they're not really adopted
very much they do solve privacy very
nicely they are also scalable I would
say more scalable than
trusted execution environments but not
as scalable as delegated accountability
the real big advantage in them is that
you have to trust only cryptographic
assumptions and because of that to the
best of our knowledge even given all the
funds in the world and all the power in
the world for a lot of these systems we
have no idea how to actually break them
and then like create a false statement
irrespective even if it's the NSA and it
one still work it's you know best or
worst to do we don't know ways that will
feasibly be able to break them so the
next part of this talk is going to be a
focus on proofs as a means you know dive
in is to this last row about proofs is a
means to deal with computational
integrity but if people want to ask
questions or like discuss now
well the third one is replaying
signature right there's some signature
your and and I should say that in all of
them you start with a replay so also all
of these cryptographic proofs also start
with a replay and then do a lot of stuff
around it it actually be while you make
while you compute it you sequentially
sounds like it could be different than
we like as you computer you can prove
that is correct - right you're saying
maybe yeah maybe in a cryptographic
proof you you you do you start with a
naive replay but then you do all kinds
of things
well III I agree with your comment that
the first three are more like we say
certainly the first two are I guess the
second one is just sort of replay by a
selected group of delegated folks right
that's the big difference that when you
trust them and then you know they tell
everyone that it's okay but in terms of
a technological way they do exactly a
naive replay and then the third one
you're right that will actually also
replay the very same computation or
you're right oh you're right it's not a
your yeah it's not actually a replay
because in a trusted execution
environment you don't have someone else
coming in and asking for it the party
that makes the claim or runs the
computation just does it once I agree so
in terms of scalability I always assume
that trust execution and wireless will
be more scalable because you have the
competition
the signature and it will be much
quicker than the question is so first of
all yeah I think ok they're much faster
but when I talk about scalability I
think more about you know how as things
grow both the length of the computation
let's say the memory patterns and things
like that
how amenable is your framework for that
so you always need more compute I may be
wrong here my sense is that but but I
may be completely wrong
like with SGX for instance you will face
all kinds of memory limits or program
size limits essentially pretty big
encompassing everything from somebody
rent on the auditing parts of a
computation to kind of the I guess the
the modern take on it is like arbitrage
true that where you have like different
parties can sort of they have a
financial incentive
to recomputation then the second bucket
is the second row okay as opposed to
call them okay
or are we Trump would fit here cuz they
involve some cryptography they have
incentives it's not necessarily a
designated right you're saying fraud
proofs are maybe a fifth role an entity
on I need to think about that I I agree
because everyone is invited to sort of
be a delegated you know Watchtower and
there are efficient ways for showing
when something wrong happened I like
that yeah so yeah yeah and it doesn't
fall into any of these it's right I
agree yeah I'll add that that's good
yeah
mark trusted execution violence is
question mark personal ability
like it really depends on the problem
you're thinking of because they're
problems where the t e's are like very
skilled like if you just like submit
your tax return or the proof that is
correctly i mean for me the definition
of scalable is what happens when you
take some parameter and you you know
increase it that I wouldn't call scaly
like many repetitions of the same
problem when I think of scalability I
think of you know there's a fixed let's
say but not like or like I would call it
like batching earlier you want to do
many you want to do many many iterations
of the same small computation or many
instances of the same small computation
I agree that in that case teaser are
gonna deal with that with no problem I
was thinking more about so maybe yeah
you're saying there's a how fast they
are or how you know how much of a
slowdown do you incur and then how
scalable it is meaning that how you know
as as this one let's say you know you're
doing something over a database sorting
it so as you take the size of the
database and increase it how does it
affect and then okay I agree yes the
second row or maybe just a trivial
solution is that you cannot have a
larger percent guarantee from if I think
from a game theoretical perspective
right if you think about it everybody
I'm a hundred percent I'm gonna check
you then I know that you will not commit
any crime if you do commit any crime I
have no incentive to check it because
not forgetting not getting any get any
reward yes it's always gonna be a mixed
strategy Nash equilibrium dad like
everything is gonna pop into this thick
then there's nothing
deterministic but I guess some of the
solutions actually can approach that
deterministic okay you're saying that if
one adds the the you know fraud proofs
then it's not quite so what Joe was
saying that it's trust in economic
setups but you're saying it's a little
more you have to do it the right way for
those economic incentives to actually be
there for it to okay that kind of helps
you because some of the solution you are
trying to provide may even have better
than that I think you could make the
same claim even about cryptographic
proofs that everybody can assume the
person won't cheat because they have to
provide a proof and then why would
anybody verify the proof right even if
it's very cheap to verify the proof
there's there's still sort of a weird
incentive problem with you I guess maybe
I maybe I don't know where is it you're
again maybe his argument is some of the
encrypted cryptographic checks are much
cheaper I hope so then they aren't you
something about like as long as the cost
is not zero your same argument applies
that everybody should assume that right
that no there's no incentive to cheat so
therefore why should I have a reply okay
that's continue I it's really great that
we're discussing and you know even if we
run out of time with the third part
that's fine
okay so now I wanna again this is very
informal I I wanted to sort of dive a
bit deeper into some of the advantages
of you know zkp is out there best of
these crypto proofs so how to think
about a proof of computational integrity
so I think a good starting point for
those who are not familiar with them is
to think about a grocery receipt
especially in the good old days when it
was all done by hand so there is a
statement of computation and integrity
the statement is that the total sum to
be paid is correct right we want so the
grocer wants to convince the customer
that this is correct
so the grocer here acts as the prover
it's the party making the claim and
trying to convince the other party and
the verifier is the one that actually
foots the bill and it wants to check it
so here what we have is really a proof
it's a string of characters that
convinces us that some computation was
done correctly in this case summing up a
bunch of numbers so there are also an
instance of a proof that it happens to
be done by naive replay right if you
want to verify this proof you're really
rerunning the same computation that the
grocer would have done to sum things up
and they have some very good advantages
they are deterministic there's like no
randomness there's no error probability
they are non interactive you get this
piece of paper that you just walk around
with it and you can show anyone so those
are big advantages and they've been
around for a while but the kind of
proofs that that we're discussing and
have interest in are of three
disadvantages and in the same areas
first of all they must use some forms of
randomness they do incur some
probability of error so it's worse than
me good old receipt and they involve
some form of interaction so it's not
like something you just walk with this
piece of paper it's some form someone
should have sent messages back and forth
so they're much worse why are they good
because they offer many many good
advantages so maybe the most
the famous one by now is zero knowledge
which you can think of as the ability to
blind some of these entries whichever
ones you choose and nevertheless have
the other party to verify be as
convinced or you know up to this small
probability that the computation was
correct okay that's the zero knowledge
property there's a separate property
that sometimes you you know you could
use it in conjunction what's your
knowledge or you could just go with it
by itself and that's the notion of
scalability which means that you have
two things at the same time you can
generate the proofs in in nearly linear
time with very little overhead compared
to just running the name of computation
and at the same time checking them
becomes exponentially smaller or
logarithmic in in the size of the
computation so now as the size of the
computation grows larger and larger you
have this bigger discrepancy between the
ability to prove something and how how
fast it is to check it and another good
attribute often referred to as
universality or completeness in various
complexity classes is that you can apply
to any computation not just the summing
up of integers but even two very common
complications
your tax returns or some of these
systems and now I'm heading more towards
a you know problem in NP problem that
ever no no no we know to construct a and
P as far as your knowledge groups or
things above NP I thought that it's only
for next but now like with these quantum
versions of it it goes to at least
doubly exponentially next when you know
there's no end in sight for now so
anyways yeah but it covers if you know
enough computation that we care about
yeah
so another attribute to some of these
systems have is is transparency which
means that all the messages that come on
behalf of the verifier are just random
coins public random coins there are no
secrets from the point of view of the
verifier often this is called no trusted
set up or public coins or it has other
names and some of these systems not all
of them also rely on very lean and you
know sort of battle-hardened
cryptography that has been around for
decades hashes and stuff like that
symmetric cryptography and this makes
them post quantum secure some of you
systems so some of you know where I'm
heading toward a system that has both
the privacy and then a zero knowledge
and this form of scalability and is
transparent we refer to it as a zk stark
there are many other names of you know
forms of zero knowledge proof that
emphasize different things the most
famous is perhaps snarks it requires it
to be non interactive but allows
pre-processing things there are Smisek
since extinct music ccs proofs and you
know a whole bunch of them and then a
variety of implementations so let's
pause here just to you know have a
discussion on
the advantages or disadvantages of these
kinds of proofs and III should say you
know the cryptographers here they're
very very thing you needed but I'm more
interested in hearing the no more social
science folks applying many call me
why philosophically there should be show
proofs for something convex yes it's
amazing now this goes back to yes
BFF yeah completely amazing
it was completely surprising back in the
day I think was the early 90s that that
at this minor price of a price of
allowing randomness and interaction you
can do unbelievable things like having a
verifier check and sort of control the
correctness of something that runs
exponentially more time in all these
systems you mean that there is
interaction hiding inside yeah it's even
the non interactive ones or you know
there's some you can sort of limit the
interaction to the very first phase
where something is selected yeah yeah
but you can't like purely non
interactive is the kids the kids
passionate somebody comes to you and
says I know how to count the number of
leaves on the tree yeah right so the non
interactive ones are still have a form
of interaction but it is very limited
for instance at the very start of time
before everyone uses the system once and
for all you know a bunch of keys is
selected but but you can't do without
that phase right it's mathematically
impossible I mean okay you are severely
restricted to non interesting complexity
classes if you do away with that and
maybe even there's no zero knowledge I
forgot are they like you know if we're
all practical purposes you need some
interaction okay
other common questions
okay so now I want to tell you why as I
view it today why I think blockchains
and crypto proofs really really go along
well
the proof the proof of I did the
computation right if I relax the privacy
I don't care about the zero loaded
things would have been much easier to do
you would have thought but I in practice
zero knowledge it's getting the proof
it's hard and we're getting a sixteenth
pro for getting a proof and in all
systems I'm aware of adding zero
knowledge in hindsight turns out to be
almost trivial and a lot of it is like
goes back to some form of this shamil
secret sharing you know you add a little
bit of randomness you know again this is
surprising you would have thought that
like it should be very hard I guess a
different way to think of it is you're
working so hard to get this notion of a
proof that by the time you got that or a
16,000 matter by the time you got that
adding zero knowledge turns out to be
not that hard okay so I mean first of
all back in the day so this was like
2013 or 2014 but I think it still is
correct like if maybe it's starting to
change if you go around and you meet
some person from the conventional world
let's say the banking system or no
healthcare and you tell them oh we have
this amazing cryptography
it's called zero knowledge proof you can
do a whole lot of stuff with it you know
they will sort of blink at you and say I
mean now they might say oh we need a PLC
to put a bullet in some presentation to
the board but like they will sort of try
to understand wait a second who's gonna
prove what to whom the bank will prove
to the customers that it's keeping its
funds correctly but what do you mean you
don't like this bank so go find some
other Bank or maybe the customer is
gonna prove something to the bank but
the bank will say what do you mean
you're gonna tell us everything about
your financial do you trust us that's
why we're here and then if you go to
people in the blockchain space and this
was true even you know six years ago and
you told them we have this thing called
the zero knowledge proof they'll stop
you very quickly and say okay here the
first of all they'll tell you here are
five applications we want now and just
show us where the code is like we don't
need to
to us why this is important so this was
something that I I sort of felt already
many years ago and anyone doing zkp s
and talking to blockchains felt it
similarly but I want to articulate why
maybe this is the the case so in the
standard world we have this notion that
we discussed of delegated accountability
right that we sort of appoint these
accountants and regulators and they go
out and check that the banking system is
ok but in the blockchain space there's
this amazing
I don't know philosophical or ethical
value of inclusive accountability which
basically says verify don't trust and
anyone with a laptop and connectivity to
the Internet is invited to sort of
download the blockchain and be part of
this big democracy of of checking that
everything is ok so this is an amazing
and powerful new concept that maybe
someday you know all governments are
gonna need to sort of stand up to or
sorry you know work in a similar way we
wish they would they're not there yet
or banks and so on but this beautiful
idea of inclusive accountability has two
downsides it sacrifices privacy
obviously everyone sees everything so
they learn everything but it also
sacrifices scalability because now if
you wanna against think of scaling up
the system 10x or 100x so whatever the
speed right now of your bandwidth is in
the strength of your laptop you need to
scale it up 10x or 100x so this is not
something that is sustainable or
scalable and I want to say that
scaleable zkp solve both problems so if
after there's zero knowledge aspect you
can solve the privacy in a very obvious
way you can see wipe could help you're
now shielding things and proving that
these shielded things are correct and
that's pretty much what the Z cache was
I think the first to do in at least in
the most extreme way and you can also
use them to scale up the system by by
just not letting everyone perform all
computation but just someone come
performance on their behalf so I want to
explain a little bit more about
scalability because privacy is more
discussed so I want to talk about
scalability so here we have a graph I
think this is about as much math as
we'll see so we would like to push our
throughput to this side right we wanna
let's say process more payments or
things like that so but but as we're
doing it we need to increase the
computation time of everyone who's
checking these poof these these things
and pretty much linearly right and in
the world we have like huge clouds with
tons of computers so there's a lot of
compute power out there right so we
could scale up just by using more
compute power but all blockchains put a
limit on the amount of computation why
because of this value of inclusive
accountability you want everyone to be
able to track everything that is going
on in the network all the time without
you know needing to buy a large
computation time from from Amazon so you
know in Bitcoin it's whatever how many
megabytes a block is limited in
aetherium the ghast limit you know does
a similar thing it limits the amount of
computation to something that is much
smaller than the amount of computation
out there in the world so now we have
this distinction between what you can do
off chain with vast computation and on
chain but we still want everyone to be
able to hold the whole system
accountable so now you see why a
scalable zkp can really help because you
can have a single prover creating a
proof in nearly linear time and then
everyone else just in exponentially
smaller or in logarithmic time verifying
that proof and then you get this big
scalability factor the larger the amount
of computation the bigger the
scalability factor and it turns out that
in many cases the amount of computation
grows so slow that you can push inside a
single block limit a whole lot of
computation so I want to say that if you
use scalable zkp you can solve the
problem of scalability while preserving
the notion of inclusive accountability
and not requiring everyone to go and
increase their computational power by a
factor of 10 every time you want to yeah
this is linear bilinear scale yes
correct
but you cannot prove data availability
right I agree yes so the data
availability is a big issue maybe we'll
get to that later I don't want to go
into it now because it's it's a separate
like all technologies GTP's don't solve
all problems and and yes I'll give an
example let's say that it processed
10,000 payments and now the state of the
system that is just captured by a merkel
route of the database moves from A to B
yeah I need to maybe you know yeah but I
think this is the the function of
logarithm and this is the function of n
log n on a linear by linear scale
since say that when I get off level here
I thought we were leaner earlier could
you repeat your last statement just what
which statement about that this I'm
saying this looks like the logarithm
function and this looks like n log n if
this is n okay but it may be that it
starts off not at zero or you know other
things but so here's a different way to
think about it so a blockchain
scalability problem everyone has these
computers and what if we could have like
one party using a much bigger computer
but then everyone else working much less
so you can do this the on chain
computation that is now carried out by
everyone there needs to check every
transaction could be replaced by
something that just verifies the proof
and then you have this prover that is
not limited to the the computational
restrictions that are on chain and it
can run on a big Amazon Cloud and then
it compresses the amount of computation
that the other nodes need to do and in
order to make this better you want to
batch many many when I move the scale or
go all the way to the right as much as
you can and then you get the bigger
savings
so any questions on this part yes so you
have been in the last stroke of wave yes
so I'll just verify whether there was a
vocation or not this involves no
assumptions and no signatures on
anything that nowhere do I require any
signatures or any person having any
secret key and anything that's a big
difference accessing accessing data
easier is a certificate to do so when
you say certificate you are in this
world the whole world of certificates is
about having some root of trust which
you assume will start signing off on
others signing off so there's this whole
notion of signing there are special
parties that are I agree but I'm saying
here this whole framework that I'm
describing you can have Darth Vader
entrusted with proving you cannot have
Darth Vader entrusted with starting off
the well he's a bad guy I don't know
who's your favorite bad guy the Joker
you cannot have that's search for me I I
want to know a poof whether there is a
you have access or don't have access and
you say I can do it for you I'm just
saying that that wave lives in a world
that is very important than interesting
and cannot be replaced by this stuff
because of man in the middle because man
in the middle is in the end I'll tell
you why because you want to know that
when you access Bank of America you're
accessing the real Bank of America but
from a computational point of view there
is no real Bank of America okay she
talked about a blockchain yes there is a
blockchain then there is I don't want to
go over all the blockchain to know
whether there was a revoke Asian or no
okay
yes location right and you see you say I
sold it with zero knowledge proven okay
why didn't she tell me she'd say oh now
we watch maybe take it off and because I
have to remember I think in her system
it is in the end signature-based but
maybe I got it wrong and in the end
there are like signatures but me am i
right is a signature based or it's a
okay so it's a it's a different you you
have more site you have different
assumptions or you're assuming that
there are some parties that are special
and they start the process here you do
not assume anything about my analogy am
I thinking about what she said is like
we all learn early early on they the
Union and you don't find problem what I
have a blockchain which says Union fine
you don't find and at the end I want to
know oh now this say node belong say
what's the name of the figured offline
like he's talking about compression of
work and proves and maybe there's a way
to play this year maybe we need to
understand what's the scope of the magic
I would take it often because I think
there are different assumptions that are
applied okay other comments on
okay so let me now instantiate this
theory in in like I want to tell you
about a product this is the product of
Starck where that will you know
hopefully be deployed in two months but
it uses these notions of scalability on
block chains so you know most of what
goes on on block chains these days is
speculation people are buying in selling
coins and if you want to participate in
this lovely activity you're gonna
probably have to lock your funds inside
a locked exchange which means you're
basically transferring custody of your
funds and they are now locked up in this
exchange the big ones are like finance
and coinbase and whatnot and now you
sort of they're taking care of your
funds and your secret keys and you give
them instructions okay
there's also the notion of free exchange
sometimes it's called miss by mistake
like decentralized exchange but it means
that while you're trading you never hand
over custody of your funds they're
always with you you can take them
wherever you want or give the keys to
anyone you want so the reason that most
of the trading these days on
cryptocurrencies is actually done in
locked exchanges because they have very
large scale and very low cost because
most of the stuff that you're doing
never appears on the blockchain it just
is you know internally in the books of
the of the exchange latency as well
right and when you do it in a free
exchange it it it is well latency
depends for what for trading it's very
fast but if you want to retrieve your
funds actually the latency right but but
I'm telling you that if you want to
extract if you want to take your funds
outside of an exchange of a locked
exchange you're gonna wait much more
time than the latency which we will be
much worse so as long as you're inside
this this nice garden you're very fast
but once you want to take it out okay
several reasons one is it's there assets
you know the keys are there especially
think about a situation of like a run on
the exchange you need to extract things
from cold wallets bring them on board
you need to have all kinds of managers
and security officials sign off on it
and so on people are not you know free
exchange you're saying everybody's in
charge of their own keys so yours that
blockchain speed you can take it
wherever you want
yeah well it's yours it's it's like each
trader decides how they keep their funds
but like other security measures I think
they I mean they would all involve huge
hot wallets that I think still be hot
would still be hot yeah and then NPCs
you know they're if you get it if you
get n minus one of them and no your keys
are you're free to do with him whatever
you want yeah okay so our then this is
you know what our company is going to do
is gonna power exchanges with easy KP
called starts and it turns out to be
extremely scalable inexpensive and also
free or non-custodial you don't have so
the the problem is that because of this
honeypot risk that like everyone is you
know putting their funds sorry the
exchanges need you to lock up your funds
with
and there's this huge honeypot you know
their meltdowns and hacks from time to
time
traders are dividing their assets across
different exchanges and then there's
this liquidity fragmentation where you
can't really sort of move your funds
very quickly from one exchange to the
other and it takes actually a very long
time to withdraw thing so those are the
current problems and first of all what
stark exchange does it eliminates this
huge honeypot there is no more because
every trader has his own funds and it
also becomes you know frictionless to
move from one trading platform to the
other and the way it works is that
currently if Alice and Bob want to trade
in a free way on the network that you
and I have to send this is on chain and
this is off chain so they're gonna have
to send some transaction to be settled
on chain and this is very costly and
that's why there's very limited scale
there our concept is that sort of this
trade is done a batch of these trades
that are going to be settled or sent to
approver and then approver generates a
proof and the proof is exponentially
smaller and what is sent to the main
chain is only this proof and the new
state of the system so here's how the
system architecture looks on the on the
etherium network we have two smart
contracts one is the big contract that
just manages everything and you know
that's the storage and the other is a
more restricted one that just verifies
proofs and then Alice and Bob and a
whole bunch of traders work on the
exchange and interact and they do their
trades they sign orders and when these
orders are matched the witch is taken
this is done by the exchange a batch of
these pairs of signed orders that our
masters are sent to settlement and now
what you have is this database and this
touches on the data availability
availability problem like where is this
data kept and what happens is that the
star kicks engine generates a proof that
updates you know it batches many trades
and it generates a single proof that
updates the state of the system and says
here's the new Merkle route for the
state of the system and this is what
goes on chain
and thence one once this is accepted by
the stork verifier the stark ex mother
contract updates the state of the system
aren't you so I just want to show you
the effect of scalability on gas price
so it's good to bear in mind with a
single named settlement if you want to
do free trading today cost around the
two hundred thousand gas so this is a
pretty large amount it means each block
in aetherium has at most eight is
limited by eight million gas so you can
do at most forty trades in a single
block and that's why it's very slow and
costly so this is the gas limit of a
single goal and what we see here is that
as the batch sizes of the number of
trades goes up you see this sort of
amortize the amortized cost in gas of
each single one this is the effect of
you know exponential or the exponential
function when you amortize it so each
time you increase the batch size the
amortize or the gas cost that a single
trade has to pay goes down so at eight
thousand trades each trade it cost like
eight hundred gas and we can now
generate all ready proofs that cover a
settlement of 32,000 trades which is
gives you a rate of two thousand trades
per second and the proof fits inside a
single aetherium block give you gives
you an amortized gas cost of two hundred
so it's a thousand times more efficient
in terms of the gas cost and I'll just
summarize and then we'll do the question
so I said sure this now will be less
than 6 million guess I don't know about
the 32k might be close to six million
maybe eight million I don't think that
usually will be running these things and
by the way the gas cost is gonna go down
once we have EAP 2028 which should be
like in two weeks so but right now so I
think this would be like slightly less
than 8 million gas and will go down
let's say four million gasps I'm
guessing and these ones are so in our
demo it was a thousand that this cost
six million gasps but it's gone down a
little bit so yes oh wait wait let me
let me just let me just summarize
briefly so I try to convince you that I
think proofs are the best way to
establish computational integrity the
minimal trust assumptions and you get
privacy and scalability I try to share
with you my aha moment that like proofs
are really really good for achieving or
supporting inclusive accountability at
scale and I told you a little bit that
this thing that will be deployed in two
months
powering diversify which is an exchange
that is basically it will offer BitFenix
is liquidity this this is you know
product it will use this kind of proof
system to scale trading on aetherium
very soon the order book is at the
discretion of the exchange right so we
are we are a settlement engine for an
exchange now the exchange can decide
what it wants to do with its order book
I think yeah they're very fair matching
currently we are not proving fair
matching but we can GTP's can do that
we're not doing that right now roughly
each order has to be signed with you
know a secret key that corresponds to a
so a vault which lets in account holds a
public key and token type in an amount
so suppose I have you know banana coin
you have Apple coin and I really want to
buy Apple coin and trading for my banana
Queen so I will assign an order saying I
wanna you know trade this pair and I
send it to the exchange maybe at the
same time you're assigning a counter
order that you want to trade so now what
the prover Prue
is that the orders were signed correctly
they are indeed you know Leafs and a
miracle tree right now the the sums are
no luck the sums traded are no larger
than the the balances that you had there
the balances after the trade were
accounted correctly and so on and so
forth yes
proved are in the exchange and yes yes
you don't have to trust the prover yes
and and the proof actually the prove
work the prover cannot pay the prover
cannot change the database in a way that
does not follow from a sequence of
orders that was actually signed and and
the prover doesn't have any of these
keys neither does the exchange so the
worst we can do if we're hacked is a
halt to system which is unpleasant and
there are mechanisms for you know
allowing people to retrieve their funds
even in this case that I didn't describe
but we cannot even if we're the most
malicious and we cannot steal your funds
or execute an order that you didn't sign
no doesnot the exchange
plasma doesn't have any ZK peas in it I
think it uses fraud proof which is this
not following sometimes you know the
plasma think is like blog posts and I
think they get it some places
descriptions of things like you know
that every transition is proven with
pants of course open the details are
missing that's a future plan
just payments yes so the CK statement is
gonna verify to two signatures and then
do like the UTS Oh update semantics yeah
like 8,000 times like so I mean more
than 8,000 yeah we can fit you know up
we can fit 30 mm so you basically what
what is the chain see it ceases I mean
it has in storage a miracle route and it
sees a new merkel route anna proof what
that these trades were settled correctly
and sequences of pairs of signatures and
the statements and the signature of the
form blonde blonde this update right
here updated i won't approve it i want
to to avoid computation computation for
me is going over the chain all over all
the change so what I want is you saved
here to take a public key and say and no
and suppose I have access to enough
to take your public key and know what is
the current balance of this birthday
account of this public key is this
something that no that's not covered by
it but also information theoretically I
mean if this has a million accounts you
need the so you need there a million
different queries somewhere this
information if you want it to be on the
chain you know it's gonna something has
to give there in terms of scalability so
part of the way scalability is achieved
here is know this information does not
go on the chain and so it doesn't solve
this problem you're gonna have to talk
to the exchange or you know find where
the data is it's not on the chain yes
yes yes yes so the exchange will give
you the information or Stark will give
you the information upon request
yes price actually it's only the start
verifier that's why it can be so so so
low because it's just verifying passions
right it's just in the i/o and you and
some logic but the hashes are the big
cost
yes oh yes oh sorry it happens off chain
but like what the verify sorry what the
proof approves is a bunch of signatures
and then a whole lot of merkel packs
right that gas cost of the verifier is
comprised of checking authentication
okay
a stark proof looks like a bunch of
hashes which in aetherium we're using
ketchup because it's very cheap so it's
a bunch of hashes and then some linear
algebra which is related to the
statements so that's what the verifier
pays it's it's the tall's up very
quickly but yes no the verified checks
no digital signatures yeah the smart
contract main thing there's a ramping
process that I didn't describe but it's
very important like when you send coins
to the exchanger retrieve them this
cannot be part of the you know now the
main chain needs to do something because
like the smart contract the Stark X
contract needs to send something to your
account
so there's sometimes a little bit more
and then there are signatures on the
main chain that's only for taking your
funds out or bringing them in your
trading does not expose any signatures
yes so everything it right yeah so
there's a there's a ramping area on
chain which is exactly where you know
funds are deposited until they're
updated in the miracle route and then
they disappear from the chain because
that now they're accounted for inside
the database and the by and the other
direction may be your last statement
catch the ramping thing there's you know
there's before you I mean I thought that
you know your say your ether would be in
your control in your accounts and would
just sign it going out of there tell me
about this ramping so from the point of
view of the etherium Network I mean what
do you see this thing keeps a Merkel
route of a whole bunch of stuff but the
chain doesn't know anything about what's
under this Merkel loop who has what okay
and you want this and then the main
chain I mean it knows of this thing but
doesn't really you know relate to it
this is like you know talks only to this
so now you know let's say ether is gonna
come here so that you can open an
account and then at some point you know
Abby is you know gonna take ether out so
there should be first of all all the
funds are here deposited here while
being traded there and then when you
want to ramp off you basically want to
say well you know from that pool of
ether that is deposited I really so Abby
is gonna say this I I really you know I
deserve whatever five ether and here's
my signature and you know it's an
immoral leaf and I have those funds so
please send them to my address and this
also has to be taken care of so this is
the ramping aspect of this thing so so
just to be clear for a little while we
have start either
our account has opened the accounts your
little startx account has the ether and
we have start kicks start ether it's
like all your c20 tokens or all wrapped
coins or you know the smart contract
will hold and then but it's still like
you know you it's an automatic process
and you can't really take that ether if
you don't only you know the keys that
would show that you have it kind of a
related question let's say we have a
couple of exchanges that want to have
the fancy start goodness and would they
be interfacing the same contracts there
hopefully yeah and then you can actually
do like net settlement across them and
move funds very quickly from one to the
other without touching the main chain
we'd like to go there like how many
tokens is there limitation on if I have
my favorites token that I want banana
coin everything [ __ ] coins the whole
thing
let's say you didn't want this your
knowledge property we're not using zero
knowledge here at all I'll say this it's
very easy relatively to make the proofs
actually formally be zero knowledge but
you gain almost nothing because without
like changing everything like the
account based model like you need to
move to some shielded UT EXO commitment
restyle Z cash model which would
significantly change the system but so
it like it is meaningless to put to make
this thing zero knowledge as it is right
now because like all the informations
leaking from everywhere around it's not
like the proofs are leaking so much
information as it is I mean they're not
formally zero knowledge but you see a
bunch of merkel paths and then some
field elements so it's not like but
they're not formally zero knowledge they
actually unique knowledge it's just not
very
good saluted compromises stunk they're
just missing something first and they
start over I have to first oh no no no
you do not have to trust so if someone
compromises the start prove er they can
shut it down no yeah no I mean assuming
there's no bug in the verifier and the
verifier you can run this on so this
goes back to the you know words of you
know the early 80s of VF LS and these
other papers you can have this running
on faulty hardware run by malicious
entities that are even in in some
settings even computationally unbounded
Alice for instance said I am winning in
the next 24 hours to sell my banana coin
for Apple coin at a certain rate right
so you can mess with the exchange
because maybe there was so she's giving
some limit order you know if as long as
it's above two dollars I'm willing to
sell it now maybe a fair exchange would
have sold it to her at ten dollars but
there's a malicious exchange here that
actually generates some some order at
exactly two dollars in sort of cheat sir
but that's yeah we're not covering this
aspect of matching at all yeah so what
so let's say Alice Bob in the exchange
the I trade a dollar and and you put it
into the star kicks what prevents you
from taking the same pair of signatures
and running the transaction again there
is a mechanism for that there is a
unique transaction idea that that
prevents this but you're right it's a
good there's there's there are a lot of
details but it's a very good point for
instance if you have many dollars and he
has many whatever let's say banana coins
usually gave one order the exchange or
us we could replay it in again and again
to deplete your accounts so there is a
mechanism in the system that prevents
this
so when you're signing on an order
there's like you're signing also on some
unique order ID and it has to be
different each time and things like that
so it is something that is preventing
this area assignment we are paying in a
counter of the total number of payments
they made so that they can't because
those groups so every payment is just
like Alice signing that she wants to
transfer X to Bob all right so you could
deplete her account okay
how are we in terms of time oh sorry
yeah I think I think yeah I think we're
out of time okay thanks a lot
no no I'd like to say okay we'll take it
off
[Applause]